welcome back to new rock stars she-hulk
episode 2 sees the incredible hulk off
to run some errands in a galaxy far far
away i wonder where he went probably
walmart but what if our first favorite
jolly green giant is on a one-way trip
on his favorite rocket ship what if big
einstein brucey b just took a one-way
trip to sakaar never to return again
until a later date this is rogue theory
the show where we fix the wildest
theories for the nerdy titles that we
love my name is mt and going rogue with
me today is the wonderful ghost host
with the most it is whitney van
lenningham what's going on with me
i'm good
yeah
it's a good nice day it's a good one
and my boy
mr off-screen producer brandon the one
who is basically the next fury of the
whole operation what's going on brandon
oh i don't want to be fury that's too
much work that's too
like with you have to pretend to die so
too much much
many times
it's a lot of responsibilities
[Music]
they love pretending people die in the
mcu it's like their favorite thing okay
but like to be fair brandon if you let
me plan your your like fake funeral like
it'll be so
so lit like you know that i would plan
you
i i'm down for that i'm down for that
okay i'm ready and the newest member of
mordo's illuminati it is tom michaelson
what's going on tom yeah i'm gonna come
in every time i walk into room it's
gonna go
play that thing just like
just like xavier shaved my head just for
this episode guys
so thanks so much for having me
i'm ready yes i'm ready i'm gonna walk
around thank you you are prepared yeah
all right guys let's get into our first
topic of the day because i believe that
there is a big possibility here that the
incredible hulk might not be on earth
616 for a very long time because uh he
is going to head back to sakaar
obviously because we have this sakaran
ship that's like hey would you guys like
to be in an accident here you go fresh
accident for you um and make it a family
of those car accidents i mean ship
accidents
you've been a car accident right that's
a car crash for you and you um but so
far
oh my god that's the best thing ever
was the best joke
i like
but um
but yeah so we know in the comic books
that hulk has a pretty close
relationship with zakar because he was
basically running that thing for a very
long time and like in the mcu we have a
different tale going on with the the
hulk fighting the grand master and
escaping with um valkyrie and korg and
the whole asgardian gang just going off
to new asgard but
i think that the mcu could be setting up
a scenario where hulk is forced to sort
of take care of the people of sakaar
after they win their freedom from the
grand master they beat this guy and he's
like yeah it's a tie but is it really a
thai grandmaster you seem pretty
outnumbered yeah so i think that hulk
with his amazing smarts is going to have
to sort of shepherd these new people
into like their new role as a society as
a planet because like these people can't
leave all these wormholes are all over
the place and like you cannot leafs a
car unless you have one of these fancy
new vehicles so i think that um hulk is
going to be staying on sakaar to sort of
be the mayor of sakhar the leader of
sakaar and um in
leaving
leaving she-hulk to be the only hulk on
the planet because you know you don't
really need two hawks on the planet if
you don't have to you know like one hulk
is enough and she-hulk seems to have a
handle on her powers a lot better than
um the incredible hulk does
mostly in the comics anyway um they're
both obviously the very same and not
breaking things at this moment but we
all know that bruce is going to mess up
soon sorry bruce not to you know have no
faith in you but we have to this your
struggle your curse
but what do you guys think do you guys
think that
bruce is going to come back by the end
of the series or is he like could he
possibly
stay on zakar for a bit and maybe
potentially lead us into a world war
hulk situation where something goes
wrong and he's pissed off that his whole
society is um ruined because of
something that earth did what do you
guys think i think he could be there for
a little bit i i like that i mean
it is like we just got him back on earth
and now they're moving him off again i
know it just got him back there was five
years there but it was a blip to a lot
of us
i mean yeah right yeah
to ship him off again seems like uh
okay you just got him here but all right
uh but yeah i think you're on to
something that he could be gone for a
little while also i don't want to blame
the sikarians uh for causing that car
accident you know they just assumed the
car would stop they thought our
technology was a little more advanced
like i myself in los angeles there's so
many teslas driving around i'm not
afraid to step out in front of a tesla
going down the road it'll stop unless
i'm small
fear brandon oh my god
brandon just has really
driverless cars but the second there's
driverless cars the people on the street
again okay once there's driverless cars
you can just walk out
they're gonna stop the robots will stop
they can't trust me
it's so like i love like to think that
like he's like hey my ship can go from a
thousand to zero in in 0.5 seconds why
not this ship that is
[Laughter]
thanos you're telling me that their cars
don't stop when an object gets in front
of it like that's done exactly
that's a very good point though because
like you know on a cosmic scale like
people think that earth is like they're
very impressed with what earth has done
they've you know stopped an alien
invasion from thanos and like they
stopped thanos again in endgame so like
these guys are probably like yeah these
guys must be super advanced um they
probably saw wakanda it's like hey the
whole planet's like wakanda right great
that's not the case
that's a big time now we have the entire
state of florida florida does not like
wakanda cannot possibly
make up for the mistakes of florida
that puts us down several evolutions it
really knocks us down like florida is
the reason why we're going to get
a hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
someday the universal bypass is just
gonna come for us all because of florida
listen as someone who's born and raised
in the sunshine state of florida i'm
here to say that you are absolutely
correct and that's all good
i'm here to defend for it by saying you
are absolutely correct
that's my defense you're absolutely
correct
but yeah like i just i love this idea
specifically because of that world war
hulk scenario that like i just want the
mcu to tackle and like let's face it
it's gonna happen eventually world war
hulk is too iconic and like it has to
happen for a reason and that reason is
um in the comics for sakaar blowing up
because the like
like his ship blew up for some reason i
think it was his fault actually but like
uh he thought it was the illuminati so
he was like i'm gonna kill everybody um
not a great thing but like hey i think
that it's this is a great way to set up
that hulk motivation for revenge and i
like a good revenge yeah i think you're
right i was thinking the same kind of
thing is that because there's rumors
rumbling that you know now that
universal's
legal hold on the hulk as a you know
solo character in movies is expiring
that marvel's gonna get that back now
they can make their own movies again
maybe this is their way to pick up the
pick up that where they left off and
make a proper hulk movie because at the
end of planet hulk which thor ragnarok
was supposed to be a little bit um you
know he doesn't he become the ruler
there right like he he kind of liberates
the people and then they look to him to
be a ruler so maybe yeah he'll come back
and then like you said being the mayor
or whatever like he'll they're just
going to try to pretend as if he never
came back to earthland yeah he didn't
leave he was like yeah i've been here
the whole time and they're going to have
him help rebuild the place and then yeah
that way when his uh when the ship blows
up that'll give him a reason to go pla
robo hulk on everybody the other the
other thing i was thinking is
i wonder if if he's not going to go
world war hulk on earth i wonder if
they're going to make him go
world war hulk on some car like for some
reason and that'll be that way they
don't have to explain bruce breaking bad
which would which would still be fun and
good though but i was wondering well
he's that he still has another whole
world that he could destroy or you know
screw up over there and i wonder if
that's kind of where they're going
um yeah the only thing they've already
introduced some of his like friends
though but because i think i think meek
was the villain actually and
the planet hulk and i think he was the
one who blew up the ship
to try to kill the hulk but he ended up
killing his wife right and the
unborn baby who ends up being born
but um but yeah that's what i was
wondering if this was either their way
to like hey now that we can make our own
movies again let's just get him back to
zakar and just continue the story and
then we'll do world war hulk and either
we'll have to come back to earth and be
mad or he can be mad on cigar and
you know destroy destroyed places over
here i don't know i'm only other thing i
was wondering is this going to be
another opportunity just to like
destroy black vault so easily because
that was one of the things i remember
from world
finding a way to just totally make the
yeah exactly and vision's like been
there man
[Laughter]
i do love this idea of hulk going crazy
on sakaar and just like smashing things
because like if you sort of think about
um like where she-hulk episode one sort
of left the hulk he sort of feels at
least his hulk side anyway he's kind of
pissed that she-hulk is out here being a
hulk and also being a strong hulk on the
planet because we know the hulk's whole
deal is he likes being the strongest
that there is if you put hulk back into
his favorite sport arena and like around
all these strong people i feel like his
insecurity could be like i'm just gonna
smash everyone to prove that i'm the
strongest man on this planet because i
want to be strong again um i can see the
whole persona like that specifically
sort of like taking over the smart hulk
and like smashing things just to let it
all out because he hasn't really smashed
since
um red ragnarok he hasn't smashed in a
while
you know what they said same here
and maybe he got a kill and yeah he's
smashing him
back then he's gonna smash again when he
arrives who knows
who knows right
he's going back because he needs to
smash yeah
all right all you got to say
asians of smash all i gotta say is that
men would rather get on a spaceship and
go to a different planet then go to
therapy get some therapy exactly exactly
that his cousin is better at being a
hulk than him and doesn't have d.i.d and
instead of just going to therapy he
leaves the planet and abandons her yes
what is wrong with him he would rather
make a fat binder than talk to a
therapist what is wrong with you you
broke my bar get out of here yeah
i'm fine with them taking hulk off
planet and doing like world war hulk
just don't like skip to the end again i
need to see hulk doing some stuff
uh like i don't know what i'm just
showing up in secret wars i've been like
i've been gone the whole time doing
these great things that you'll never see
in the mcu uh if they're gonna do the
whole thing do the whole thing but i
think you're right mt that i don't know
if there is a standalone hulk movie
that's worth doing if hulk is
is not dealing with like bruce versus
hulk right like that is like the main
thrust of a lot of it uh and it's kind
of a shame that we saw
so little of just hulk holding it down
on sakhar for two years right right when
bruce is like oh i've been gone for two
years i don't remember anything yeah how
was this hulk able to stay hulk but stay
contained obviously the grand master was
doing some control but i think it shows
that the hulk is maybe evolved a lot and
has a lot of control and all this rest
time you know bruce says it's like a
blending of the two but it's not a
blending of the two my man hulk doesn't
have any say in what smart coke is up to
he's he's being used but if all this
time like smart
smart hulk has been waiting and like
biding his time and as soon as he gets
bruce away from his planet away from his
gamma lab hulk's gonna come out again
and be like you're mine now [ __ ] well
yeah i'm never going back it's me now
baby
the world war hulk story but it would be
fun rather than him coming to earth and
having his grievances because i don't
even know if hulk has grievances on
earth no one no one hates the hulk on
earth anymore if if they just go after
another planet and if like hulk is
taking over sakhar he's the mayor sakhar
uh and he's like we're gonna go invade
this planet called you know chechmia uh
and then go and do it and like he just
starts taking over other planets and
suddenly nova corps comes to earth or
what's left of them and they're like
guys you need to deal with your hulk
problem here he's taking over the galaxy
someone's got to stop him
uh that's that i'm fine with all that
i'm fine with all that no i i love that
because like i can totally see
hulk biting his time like trying to
waiting for the moment for bruce to get
off planet to uh take over the body and
like to be like yeah back out the car
let's do it let's stop this be bad now
because i i'm too dumb to figure out how
to get off the planet again because that
quinjet was really lucky the first time
yeah first of all i just want to talk
about how hulk even was able to operate
the quinjet like how did he know how to
like hang up on nat like i don't know it
was just very weird he was kind of smart
remember i think because he gets on the
quinjet that ultron was on with the
cradle right he throws the cradle and
throws ultron out or whatever uh and
he's on this ship i think ultron knew
about sakhar he was about to destroy the
planet earth and he knew sakhar was like
this you know uh cross points of the
galaxy right it's this kind of like
end-all catch-all place of the universe
uh and we know from what if that ultron
ultimately will
strive to get the infinity stones and
take over the universe that'll be his
ultimate goal uh so i think he was aware
of it he was like well i'm about to
destroy earth it needs a little time to
kind of reset uh and while that's
happening as this is all happening i'm
going to fly off to sakaar uh and go
take over there because that's what the
grand master is and i know about the
grand master because i'm ultron uh i'm
going to take over uh destroy him
because move on from this ultron so yeah
because ultron uh he's ultron uh and
then so that's i think hulk was on that
ship and it was just like beep bow beep
and like
he he was smart enough at that point to
do some things yeah obviously he hung up
the phone and and things like that yeah
maybe he's trying to turn up the ball
you can unmute
so yeah i think he just got lucky and
that ship was going to go to sakaar with
ultron and he just like rode rode
alongside
was just in it baby that doesn't make
sense because like in what if we do know
that ultron goes directly to sakaar at
one point like he just bee line to force
a car and destroys that planet so like
he must have maybe some knowledge that
sakar exists kind of crazy i just have
like a question here uh that i can't
stop thinking about which is what is the
salary for being the mayor of fight club
planet like what
how much does that pay because
even in like our our
fine fine
earth uh
public public servants are not paid very
well and i'm just kind of like what's he
going to do he's going to go be the
mayor the mayor of tyler durden town for
a little bit
maybe he gets the castle maybe he gets
like service maybe he has a master of
coin and we can ask him yeah we don't
know maybe like a king type situation
hey i think that your theories are right
but i just want to say that i personally
would never take this job
that is the last lasting place like i
just wouldn't i just wouldn't want to in
my but hulk himself is a weird person
because well he's not really weird i
guess it's like sort of a matter of
circumstance because hulk is a big
hulking monster that has like a lot of
emotional issues and a lot of everybody
on earth hated him for the longest time
and i feel like that's why hulk didn't
want to show back up on earth in
infinity war i think that he just
doesn't like being on earth yeah man and
so like zakar he was living large he had
his own
the grand master loved him so much that
he gave him his own room he had his own
face
like yeah i'm chilling this is my
element like i live here thor you can go
if you want i don't give a like it's not
really my thing he wanted thor to stay
he was he literally destroyed the
quinjet he was like stay here it's the
best place in the world
um when it's quite terrible it's
great terrible literally the worst place
to be i agree with all of you guys i
agree with your theories i'm just saying
for me personally that is not a job that
would work out very well for me
personally i just had the opportunity no
no yeah
i was actually thinking like a health
care like
um i was thinking uh actually what was
what would get them off planets it's a
car and you know i was thinking what if
you know they show up here like yo hulk
you got a kid and they're gonna be born
any minute and he's like they just serve
him with like alimony papers right yeah
they're like you need to get back and
figure this [ __ ] out yeah cause you know
as i think their memories were emerged
so he so bruce should know about this
but at the same time yeah hulk was
living it up as a celebrity on the car
he probably had so many people throwing
themselves at him and he was like yeah
old smash right and now he's got child
support yeah that's what i'm wondering
if they're gonna
yeah that's also where they're going
with this i think i think the sikarian
showed up and they had you know they've
taken over they've they've deposed the
grand master they have a new government
new democracy and they're like look
we've been uh you know we've been going
through some of the footage you killed a
lot of people in the
ring we're gonna bring you up on war
crimes and bruce was like what excuse me
he's like okay okay he's telling jen
like uh i gotta go i'm gonna use the car
i'm gonna go deal with a couple of
things but when he gets there he's gonna
kill all those but he's gonna kill him
all he's gonna be
okay you're bringing me back but you
bring back this and this as well let's
go baby show me the evidence
[Laughter]
for real but okay i think it's time for
judgment time all right i'm ready for
the judgment do you think this theory of
hulk leaving the planet to go us a car
and to like you know stay off of earth
for
at least a very long time
is rogus bogus or ogus
take it away whitney rogues is hell dog
i think
i think he's going to be there to stay
for a little bit i think he's got
business to attend to yeah business oh
he's got a big-time business
business in every way
if you know what i mean he's truly the
nick cannon of cicada just kidding
number 10.
he's such a sick bird hulk cannon
yeah what do you think tom oh rogue is
for sure he is definitely i think going
there because that's the world the most
of his story outside of earth has been
and they're bringing us a caring ship i
think they're they're either setting up
for a new hulk story or uh with world
war hulk or something where marvel has
the rights or they're they're trying to
explain why i mean they're trying to
give she-hulk her own chance to be her
hulk without bruce having to be there
it's a way of like not killing him off
and not you know writing him out of the
show
giving him a way to do stuff but we'll
not taking the spotlight away from uh
from jan walter so rogue
and i also do think that it's kind of a
huge endorsement to
uh her capabilities as a hulk because he
wouldn't have left the planet if he
didn't think that she was ready to
take it out on her own and after like
you know training with her and realizing
like oh no she kicks ass in every
imaginable way i think that like that
it's it's cool it's like it's cool it's
like a loving gesture to be like hey i
believe in you you got this girl like
like my cousin can can hold it down
while i'm off world like that's sweet i
like it i think he's supportive yeah
it's it's super nice because like bruce
is technically the strongest being on
the planet right now yeah
wow wanda's gone carol's never around
because she's tough
he's having fun and
and uh you know he's just the strongest
one so
he's like hey now you're the strongest
one thor has a hat that would beg to
differ with you there
okay
this is true
[Music]
[Laughter]
what about you brandon what you think uh
i'll say i'll say rogus leaning ogus
only in the sense that they can do this
they can take them off keep them off
earth for a long time but they got to
give me something in between
uh now and whenever he comes back i need
to see something give my boy hulk a
standalone movie
let angry hulk back out let's let's go
let's go i would have loved some sort of
prequel story where it happened during
the 18 months because we definitely got
robbed of that you know when end game
started and he's on smart home it's like
what it's like how cool would that have
been to see him
yeah and then come out the other side of
small smart hawks i would have loved
they still can do it i would love kevin
feige you can still do it like i would
absolutely love if marvel studios
released a series of shorts sort of like
i am groot where it's just bruce's like
journey on the car and like his um what
he was doing during the blip it's like
bruce banner like shorts like what's he
doing he's just doing stuff like that's
called elf shorts
absolutely
well thank you guys for listening to my
uh weird theory i got a lot of weird
theories every week but up next brandon
the man himself has a theory about a
rogue king flying around out there which
is kind of very interesting but first be
sure to check out near
rockstarsmerch.com where right now we
have two latest obsession shirts
available our she-hulk inspired lady
justice shirt as well as our ash and
ruin shirt celebrating house of the
dragon are limited edition shirts and
will not be available forever and when
you purchase elitist obsession shirt you
unlock the opportunity to get a custom
shout out that will appear on the bottom
of our after shows which are pretty
great um and you can support the channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
we also want to thank bluechu for
sponsoring this video because with a
holiday weekend just around the corner
we want to make sure that you have all
the fireworks you need for a little
celebration in the bedroom who can help
give you that extra bit of confidence
when it matters most bluechu is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viabra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost and you can take them any
time day or night so you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever an opportunity
arises and the process is simple sign up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of our
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved they'll receive your
prescription within days not weeks days
and the best part it's all done all
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy because
lines suck blue chews tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you want to keep that
summer of love vibe going all year long
give yourself that boost of confidence
and head on over to bluechew.com and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth for free when
you use our promo code rogue at checkout
just pay 5 shipping that's bluetooth.com
code rogue to receive your first month
for free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank blue chew for sponsoring
this podcast and boners everywhere um
all right brandon
has our second topic for today so please
take it away oh yes so i've been
noodling on this idea lately uh and it
involves our boy steve rogers who we all
love so much captain america they call
him the first avenger uh what what a
sweet guy so altruistic so kind sorry
man good man so beautiful
[Music]
but i think that steve rogers is a kang
okay
uh and here's why here's why you can't
trust this guy at all yeah tell me why
okay that's pretty good holy [ __ ] that's
a big accusations
rogers is a king ladies and gentlemen uh
this little scrawny boy shows up out of
nowhere all of a sudden his parents are
dead how convenient how convenient he
gets
injected the most important thing uh
that exists on earth at that time which
is probably the super soldier serum it's
pivotal
it's an iconic thing this allows him to
extend his life beyond the parameters of
a normal man uh he then goes on through
all the adventures of the mcu that we
know and love uh and he's entrusted
with the security of five of all
six infinity stones
to take them back in time and put them
where they're supposed to go right or so
and what what happens at the end of that
he doesn't do the last part he doesn't
show back up right and all of a sudden
this old man shows up and he's like hey
sam wilson you could be captain america
now i've been banging out this chick for
100 years it's i'm tired
and then
he just walks away i guess from this
this little bench by the lake uh and no
one has any idea where he is is he dead
is he alive we don't even know
uh
i think he's a king okay and i think
that when we saw him in end game as an
old man he hadn't just like gone and
like lived out of life with peggy i
think he's obsessed with extending his
life beyond the parameters of a normal
man
and that's because he's a kang he's
obsessed with time he's obsessed with
the infinity stones and when they gave
him the stones to go back and put him in
a place he didn't do that he went back
and he put him in a way to manipulate
the timeline as he sees fit i think that
steve rogers king will be revealed to be
a mortise
uh and i think that that old that old
steve rogers that we saw he hadn't just
lived one life with peggy because i
think he would have outlived her so
easily i think that was a that was that
old version of steve rogers was an old
old version that had gone through
multiple rounds in the timeline it's
just been in the washing machine right
just crafting this perfect timeline for
himself creating like branches and and
send offs wherever where they are but
like he's formed his own perfect
timeline and that's what he went back to
there's a timeline where this steve
rogers has complete control has all the
infinity stones and is a mortise and he
it is his own world that he's crafted
for himself
uh and whether he's good or bad is not
for me to say uh because he came back
and he gave sam the show he's like you
go on you deal with this timeline i'm
done but i think that steve steve rogers
we know
is is a kang maybe he didn't know that
from the jump but now he knows and he's
just living in a little time circle that
he he loves so dearly
that's my theory oh
like his own little
love especially with this like a mortise
angle like i love the idea of steve
rogers being like the the he who remains
of his universe because like in the
comics he remains this wrinkly old white
man right and uh why not if they want to
go super comics accurate it's like hey
here's chris evans okay
he definitely uses bluetooth
just
during that uh council of kang phase you
know that oh
of yeah
masturbation at that point it's all it's
all you i'm sorry
it's just yourself
sorry but no um this idea of steve
rogers being a kang would be
a massive massive reveal for the mcu and
also just like
goes to show like how devious a kang
could be it's like hey i am secretly you
know plotting my seeds in different
people and like hey anybody could really
be a king like what if like he was like
a kang sleeper agent he's like i was
actually good boy steve rogers for my
whole life and then i remember that i
was king and i'm actually evil yeah so
uh i don't need this shield because she
wants to go disgusting
and i think i think he's like he's like
a good kang and i like he likes the 616
and i think he's kind of protecting it
from the outside you know we had he who
remains on the inside kind of keeping it
safe but now he's gone and so all hell
can break loose but i think this kang is
on the outside and he's like i like that
little universe they were so nice to me
they gave me my powers
they gave me the stones
i like that one that lady let me sleep
with her in 1940 whatever yeah
but i think i think the only way we get
chris evans back in the mcu as captain
america is if it's like a big twist i
don't think he wants to come back
as like nice boy cap we've had that
story it's done i think the big reveal
would be that like oh i found out i was
a kang and so i'm i'm living the dream
baby living the dream
you know i i was uh i was thinking i
wasn't on board at first but then yeah
when you tied it into a mortise and then
and then you know and also thinking
about they could this could be their way
to do almost like a hydra cap like that
we never there's a lot of stories
we never got because you know you can
only fit so much into these movies and
yeah and like this could be a way to
like you said like to get chris evans
back because then it could be like look
it's not really you and that way you're
not tarnishing what you did and
um and worked and it's tying it into
what's coming with like secret wars and
stuff like people think secret invasion
is gonna have reveals if this is true
everyone's mind's gonna explode it's
gonna be insane if this is freaking true
and then i'm just gonna be like brandon
was right oh my god brother was right
his biggest fear as revealed by wanda
was like the war ending right he wants
constant struggle constant war i think
he'll find his piece with peggy and
realize that's not what he wants and
peggy just dies he can't and he keeps
going through time and peggy will always
die but like he lives on he exists also
like how did he get to the bench he has
his control of time on his own somewhere
and that's in his own universe
he's got his stones and stuff yes
we got to kill steve rogers he's gotta
go what if steve rogers is like we gotta
kill secretary
we gotta kill him
oh but like what steve rogers has like a
doctor strange ass like motivation is
like collecting peggies from different
realities like one peggy's not enough i
need every one peggy for every minute
that i miss out for you guys i love you
whenever you know it yeah
like a giant spaceship shows up uh and
it's it's steve rogers
as as a mortise at the head and every
crew member is a peggy they're all just
different peggies
he's just like i need him peggy i've got
everything
did he revive the piggy from doctor
strange and there's like a half piggy
there that was like oh you guys are i
mean oh thank god yeah all the piggies
everywhere
every peggy
every peggy comes back even uh the what
if zombie universe peggy oh yeah yeah
oddly enough yes yeah
when we say all peggy's we mean all pigs
all peggy's we're not we're not around
here we're not giving
it's all of them
exactly we commit here um but yeah no
this idea of steve rogers being a king
especially with uh what tom said about
hydra cap like i can i would love to see
like kang secretly being like yeah hydra
i'm yeah i'm on your side but like it's
like a double double cross yeah yeah
it's like i'm secretly king and i'm just
taking over hydro that's taking over the
world because i just want to take over
the world ah
that would be crazy that'd be crazy i'd
love it that's a real secret war
scenario that's a big secret big scene
big secret that's a big little secret
that might start a war it might start a
war
online for sure
[Laughter]
but all right gang um i think it's time
for voting yeah what do you guys think
about this idea of steve rogers being a
secret kang i think it's pretty damn
rogues it's it's
super rogues so i'm going to give it
three rogues one rogue is stacked on top
of another rogus oh my god another
reason
oh man well i i hate to cut you down but
i am going to give it an ogus because
i really like
the theory
so much and so much of it would make
sense i just i don't know
that's right hey that's fair i want it
to be considered
or bogus
i think i think that it's august in my
opinion i love it i love it i just don't
know about it yes no i i bought the same
trim as whitney but like i just gave him
rogues because like super rogue no
yeah i think if this was like what is uh
what does tom want to happen it would be
august but it's not this is world theory
and that's one rogue ass
rogue ass theory so i'm also going to
give that
rogue because i'm like that is just so
crazy
uh and broke some would say and uh and
it got me thinking about things i never
thought about something you know and
that's what this that's the show's about
that's what the mvc should be about so
i'm gonna go with you
i'm gonna go with you on that one rogue
team rogue team i love you guys all
right
um
but now it is time speaking of being
rogue it's time for a rogue question you
guys want a rogue question yeah yeah
yeah
whether or not you're ready for it
because here it comes video this week
has surfaced of
crime happening in real life jamila
jamil was out as titania vandalizing
she-hulk billboards in los angeles as
some part of a viral marketing campaign
they say it's viral marketing but i
think that she needs to be arrested for
real my goodness just kidding it's
actually a viral market um but um so
since that happened um what would be the
roguest way a comic book villain could
cross realities to do some viral
marketing in our world so do viral i
mean viral marketing or crimes or a
biggest both
can be both could be both okay okay
there's synonyms it's fine
viral marketing is a crime i agree
marketing is a crime you tell me you
tell me i'm being marketed too don't
sneak it in on me don't sneak it in yeah
right
and this episode is brought to you by
blue by the way
yeah we're on the up and up here at the
rock stars
we're on the up and up is funnily enough
the slogan of blue
it's what they tell their investors it's
a really a universal a very versatile
tool yeah
i think you could do if if you were
doing the next we know batman 2 right
there's rumors they want to do freeze mr
freeze dr freeze is he a doctor mm-hmm
mr freeze he isn't doctor
he's a mister as uh
yeah that's that's that's very humble
right okay so you're gonna have batman
too you have mr freeze batman it's
always you know because of nolan chicago
was used as gotham a lot right i see you
have mr freeze come to our world and he
freezes the chicago river uh and you can
like and they you can ice skate down in
honor of batman too but because he is mr
freeze
he freezes it while there's still like a
tour boat and everyone on the tour boat
gets frozen
uh you know and things like that so
there's people put in peril but it's
still kind of a cool marketing thing i
think that would be fun they'll thaw out
don't fall
he's a villain so you gotta you gotta
have some
some uh people put in harm's way i'd say
he just freezes everybody's wives it's
like hey if i can't help my wife
[Laughter]
sub-zero
put sweaters on the peggies
all peggies need sweaters
i don't know what i'm saying all right
it's funny that you used to talk about
because i was thinking
uh
i was thinking
that you know i've been i've been like a
lot of people i'm worried about uh
climate change and global warming and i
was like if poison ivy could come here
and start making more plants growing
more trees
let's come up with more fuel that's
actually a very good answer that would
be great pop-up gardens in different
cities
and she could be thinking she's like
doing major
i made this forest here i'd be like
thanks actually that's great because we
got some deforestation going on we need
to get more yeah yeah
you turned some gas stations into pop-up
parks with like exactly yeah
yeah like if the batman 2 does tackle
poison ivy i think this is a fantastic
way to market the movie it's just like
you just make like you know like
concrete places like super vegetative
and like overgrown and stuff yeah filled
with that's a freaking important
disaster write that one down for a
couple years from now
that's a free one but don't don't write
it out
not right this way you got it you gotta
use the whole thing from start to finish
okay
yeah
exactly
what you think whitney okay
listen
listen you guys i understand that the
question is comic book characters i get
it
but
what is go wrong
instead
i told you guys that uh vin diesel is
already basically doing this in real
life with the fastest of the furious uh
tenth installment um
first first stunt first stunt he
pisses off the director justin lin who
has worked on
nine previous films with him
and it to the point where he left the
franchise entirely he was like i am
never working with vin diesel again this
guy sucks the same thing happened to the
rock the last time the rock tried to
hang out so i think that in this in this
scenario vin diesel is the real life
villain and uh the second thing that
happened very recently is that an entire
uh neighborhood in los angeles filed a
complaint against against the fast 10
because they were drag racing in the
neighborhood and they were like this is
too loud too dangerous too fast too
furious
like the city of los angeles already
just like hates this guy the directors
quit i think that we are looking at real
life super villain vin diesel who is
absolutely viral marketing the [ __ ] out
of fast 10 to make all of us go god damn
it i have to see this i have to see this
movie that's destroying my neighborhood
entire neighborhood sense of community
however
in communities masterful marketing by
vin diesel by the way
[Laughter]
like i imagine he was like he was like
the nicest guy he's like no this is all
for the marketing like just
fine like i'm a really nice guy really
sweet person i don't know i think that
you kind of do have to be like a pretty
big dick to make the rock maddie yeah i
feel like wayne johnson is like so nice
like he seems like the nicest like just
person in general and i cannot imagine
trying to start beef with dwayne goddamn
johnson that just is a recipe for
disaster that man has survived every
goddamn disaster movie of the 2010s okay
and you don't mess with him you don't
mess you just don't okay anyway exactly
and he survived all the violence of
wrestling which i was told recently is
very real um
i had a week to really think about what
i said
and uh i would like to apologize to all
the wwe fans uh aew i don't know what
else is there want to piss off the
internet wrestling community empty
they'll come for you they'll come for
you
a and w
right the center of a ring
exactly
but no these are all super rogue ideas
but i'm gonna have to give this uh rogue
theory question winner to mr tom
michaelson
imaginative
poison ivy um marketing because i really
want to see that because i'm a big fan
yeah that would be a good way to help us
offset our uh carbon footprint they're
just getting poison
over here on our behalf
the best way to reduce your carbon
footprint it's like recycle oh
we could be like okay
just call her yeah
we missed the spot but oh no
over there
exactly um i think poison ivy would make
a great villain for uh the batman to you
personally bro she would eliminate all
the plastic straws so fast there would
be no more plastic
all the turtles would love us the
turtles would survive so hard
it would survive the system would be
thriving
on every beach and then the babies are
gonna crawl back into the ocean when
they're old enough
[Laughter]
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks to our amazing guest
whitney van langham tom michelson and
off-screen producer brandon barrick the
man himself support our channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at new rockstarsmerch.com it really
helps us and if you got some thoughts of
your own um for rogue theories you can
share them on our discord just make sure
that you are 18 years old and older so
you can click that link in the new
rockstars uh description you can join
the server today because we'd love to
have you love chatting with you you guys
are amazing but thank you guys so much
for watching this video and spending
some time with us you can follow me at
mastertainment you can follow the
rockstars on all social platforms we'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you